p-a-r-t why because i gotta that's right
before chuck russell we didn't ask for
more
sorry
cobra kai
season four episode eight
party time today
what's that reference
oh geez i wonder it was it a 1989 film
with
ralph macchio what was the name called
9000
ah outsiders that's it
all right guys if you guys can go ahead
and strike that like button would very
much appreciate it subscribe and get
accepted into the reject nation by
you know uh by subscribing
to
that note so full-length watch alongs
where you sink it with the time code or
over at our patreon page become a super
reject today but checking out all the
crap john humphrey himself has to offer
over there thanks to the boys at prepper
for helping us edit down these
highlights also thanks to andy g for
being here our cobra kai expert guys
let's get to it strike first strike hard
no mercy the way of the fist
[Music]
anthony's suspended
oh yes stingray where have you been all
season stingray
last time we saw him with season two
gotta go sorry that's right i forgot
raymond you like to hang with a bunch of
kids and play kung fu all day it is
pathetic
pissed off the stingray
it's cobra kai
my name is stingray yeah i know
you still stink ray
stick right
that is so much more appropriate yeah
you've done this
we're messing with the cobra
you get the fangs
i like the better wolf of wall street
that actor i wouldn't be here if not for
you
and i'll do anything to prove my loyalty
kiss me
you gonna go to prom
he's gonna ask her
let the rich kids have their stupid
party
besides can you picture me in a ballroom
dress i think we're gonna see you in a
ballroom dress today's lesson is about
balance
not the way miyagi doe teaches it
he's standing back there not a student
anymore
you're gonna let me in
maybe they would if you went with me
[Music]
strictly a tactical move mm-hmm short
notice we'd have to get a ride
still need a tux i think it's a great
idea
if you're going
you're going in style
you guys remember that line from the old
budget
[Laughter]
you will never be cobra kai
you get that
this is a test right oh
ray spider-man homecoming reference get
the hell out of here
even terry was like not cool hey come on
in make yourselves at home amanda hi oh
hi hi
i'm good to see you
yeah
here we go uh-huh
well whilst you're shooting together huh
yeah yeah i think since i had that
look so fight
so do you
oh you look so sexy i wore a pink tie to
my prom just
yeah
or a pink vest i can't believe we
finally get a night to ourselves
yeah no karate no rivalry picture time
everyone let's go diaz's get together
it does look like terry silver
all right everybody now come on one big
happy family let's go
find your spot
even louie can get in the picture three
party time
well looks like it's just us tonight
what should we do
uh is that a trick question watch iron
eagle johnny
ooh
shannon this is carmen his girlfriend
silver he came by my apartment today and
he gave robbie a car
to take to prime and he gave me this
said he wanted to make sure robbie was
taken care of damn since this is cobra
kai or whatever you need to handle this
i will
i'll take the money now
i can't wait to see a terry silver
johnny lawrence fight
come on hawk you got to dance in the i
heard logan wings after party got
cancelled because his little brother got
in some middle school fight it's not
supposed to make us feel better because
everyone else's night is ruined yeah
pac-man jacket
a-plus i just flew in
what about your dad's wedding oh i'll
get back in time
you're more important
wow you really do like me no you have no
idea
oh wow
dimitri it's what happens when you join
dojo you get hot girls
let's
go oh buddy
ask her
ask her
high heels
for nothing left the hawk you shouldn't
have the hawk at home
right right
tonight is just about us kyler spiked it
they're gonna realize they're nothing
without karate
oh damn
damn look at that terry silver money
wow boy howdy the both of you
i'm sure robbie would be allowed on
school grounds yeah cousin vanessa she
wants to help out with anthony
no offense but if we're gonna get a pro
we can do better than marissa tome jr
marissa told me i got that reference
buick skylock that's a good one tell
them what you told me about ant
well i mean i can't say for sure what
his deal is okay well that's too bad
he has environmentally induced
disruptive mood dysregulation disorder
possibly related to a screen dependency
or full-blown igt
i'd want to look at the diagnostic and
statistical manual it's an evolving
science
she is marisa
[Laughter]
watch this my biological clock is taken
like this upstairs second door on the
left oh that's not how this works i
don't want to talk to him
i want to talk to you oh uh this is how
she talks to him at home in real life
oh yeah come out you sons of [ __ ]
this is a gym
we never see them use this chip
terry calling him hello hello johnny
what's your favorite scary movie
oh [ __ ] prom is a special night
did you even know he was going
as long as robbie's with me i'm gonna
take care of him deserves so much better
you listen to me you're an ancient piece
of [ __ ]
so i'm gonna kick both of your asses
back to the nursing home i would love to
see you dry corner of magnolia and like
that's where i cooked hot dogs guys dude
we could go there right now
they were good hey
what are you up to
[Music]
we'll tell you if it's authentically
linker shim and magnolia yeah
you can just tell by the traffic yeah
they're gonna have a dance off oh please
dance off they saw guardians of the
galaxy put on a show then
now dig on this
aren't you over using the dice move a
little bit there man
[Music]
oh my god they're also professional
dancers damn it's the terry silver money
yeah you have to do a 12-hour day
it's arthur murray
[Laughter]
[Music]
god they should ditch karate and just
you guys can go dancing with the stars
look at youtube dancing
[Music]
getting in their heads love it say you
didn't consider the ramifications of
giving him his own electronics
look on their faces that anthony may
have learned key life lessons from the
internet rather than from you no well
listen i'm sure he picked up some things
if we didn't realize
were you able to correct the behavior
look we discipline when it's appropriate
yes
always i mean too much
yeah
no we're just working through this we're
not acting out i can prove it with a
simple test
oh no now why do you think you love your
daughter more than your son
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was good
this place has been a dojo they're
putting it up for sale
oh is that from part three the candle
shop
yeah
in part one this place was always good
to us and it will be again except when
miyagi kicked our asses as far as
surprises go
this is a good one this is not your only
surprise
i'm taking you to prom
i'll be right back
almost in arnold schwarzenegger
reference
the stingrays gotta move for you my
place come to seven zero one zero hall
brent tell everybody
samantha stop siri you're a good dancer
thank you i love this manipulation but
if i could just win this one time then i
could look at that trophy and know i was
best on something
they are good together mm-hmm yeah
are you still watching
i don't care
that's the right answer sam
what
stop dancing right there yeah
another side of the room create space
he's gonna beat the [ __ ] out of them
like miyagi i could tell you guys a
bunch of fun facts about the dojo
come on out
ouch whoa
damn that's all terry silver the only
way that loser has a shot at winning the
tournament is with the ds kid right
how's that kid's confidence gonna be
when he sees a sensei beat into a pulp
he's your son terry unlike him i
actually heed your lessons captain
[Music]
oh [ __ ] lawman lawrence
[Music]
looks like larussa taught him some
defense
okay pretty boy
let's go
oh
no
that had me going so much
he broke two boards though points let
him go
you know i thought you knew better than
to question me i thought this is what
you wanted
oh my god stupid stupid stupid
man terry's really try and that is not
the real lego ship in magnolia guys
[Laughter]
party time
mike's gotta have the two drinks in his
hand duct tape i'm gonna start pushing
these buttons and i'm gonna call the
cops oh it's not stinkray
it's definitely not going to jail for
assault
high school kids love him
i get older they stay the same this
tournament stuff has just made me lose
focus on the things that are most
important you know i hope you guys win
okay screw cobra guy on that we can
agree
oh
damn it give me that anthony
okay it's not even an ipad okay
apparently it's games this is
that dead are you insane
learn to listen to us and do as you're
told and if you don't
you better strap yourself in for one
hell of a rough ride because i am done
playing games
i thought he was going to order another
one on alexa you know more lapusso's in
this house just so smart seems like
you're always behind me in line i'd kick
your ass but promised your mom that i
wouldn't
stay the hell away from my family i
don't take orders from tiny little
[ __ ]
dress fight
oh party time no no no no no no
whoa one two three
what are you doing doing what johnny
said i'm not taking your [ __ ] anymore
[Music]
get in there robbie
oh no
you broke mine too
whoa
oh this is crazy
tag team
oh
teenage mutant ninja turtles move
[Music]
who's going in the pool
three of them
[ __ ] this is the greatest night of my
life
[Applause]
damn wow you managed to stay dry help me
out oh throw them in
i want to go home
me too
they manipulated them why'd you drink so
much oh man kick
i don't know what that means let's get
oh man terry's this old man okay look um
you're gonna get here i'm gonna head to
bed okay we get talk in the morning wait
a
minute
i want to be a father to you
but oh went to so bad
you're doing just fine
i love you
oh
i love you too robbie
oh
no
no
no damn dead it's like a heartbreaking
jesus christ
[ __ ] rollercoasters
oh miguel
i think the highlight of my night was
still your dance booth
thanks to get dry pretty quick i guess
we should get our money's worth
wow
okay i did some dumb things to that kid
and it went way
too far and you know maybe i could help
out you know in the dealership or hang
out the dojo again if if that's cool
cobra kai worked
eagle fagg i mean i can't break more of
his stuff well i don't know what kind of
miyagi magic you pulled but
not miaki magic it worked
oh no it was drinking everyone's drunk
this episode that's why they call it
party time you ask any of the students
here
uh what they think of stingray and they
want me on the team sir it's like didn't
you see me richard jewell you want to be
called for kai
hmm so you want to become ricardo
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah
all right get part three
that was a roller coaster that would
yeah just a little bit
kind of roller coaster every emotion
that was intense that was nonstop you
know when chris first stood up
or like put terry in his place
what was so great about who's that place
terry thomas and griffith thomasine
griffith what's great about his
performance
is
as much as he was like you know
submissing some means becoming
submissive towards um
crease
there was something already kind of
scarier about him doing that because
there he kind of seemed like a feral
child about the whole thing and then
this like desperation to prove himself
to crease
be like it he felt more unhinged already
and then to see where he's gotten to but
at this point i'm like it's an
interesting thing they chose to do with
this by by chris putting him in his
place he actually became scarier
as he became as he started feeling
weaker towards the situation
and i think that's just such a
fascinating direction to take him it's
not like what you would probably expect
where he's like trying to take over the
dojo and become leader it's really that
he um
there's there's uh
there it brings it back to his like war
times you know and it's pretty nuts it's
gnarly it's a great it's a great
performance you know like he's just so
desperate to get his approval and be
validated by crease
and it's like chris brought this out of
him because chris ignited him and this
is to see where he was at the first
episode
terry
where he had his [ __ ] together under
control and then this button gets
activated and just slowly deteriorating
and moving backwards
that's nuts man that's uh that's some
good writing i think he's going to be
doing some cocaine yeah
old ladies over oh yeah if the next
episode doesn't start with like a coked
out montage yeah i hope so
poor stingray man i know
someone had that great night with that
party and then got his ass kicked a
party with a bunch of high schoolers
yeah yeah yeah and assaulted his
neighbor who i'm sure we'll call the
cops yeah he's gonna go to jail anyways
might look at that yeah perhaps man
um this was a wild one this was a wild
one uh that
i don't even know where to begin that
that that freaking um
scene with williams obco but he was
crying on the bench
oh they just pulled the heartstrings
this show doesn't really get me to cry
with that [ __ ] that that moment got me
crying that was that was really
heartbreaking oh yeah the way they deal
with
that whole thing of just the the
complexity of all the
different dynamics is like for robbie to
say that thing to miguel about how you
think he just what really wants to be
your dad he's just doing that's trying
to make up for what he did for for what
he did to me
and then to have that moment where it
just [ __ ] with your heart as an
audience member of
of uh no it's you know johnny just loves
me and wants to and wants to be like a
dad to me but he's really thinking of
robbie
like wow i can't believe the show just
did that so so heartbreaking just keeps
messing with you man
as much as the characters are being
thrown off balance we too are being
thrown out yeah yeah
yeah yeah and and it's showing how
the trajectory of where these characters
are going of how like when johnny was
fighting with terry he was doing some
miyagido moves
when
um
so much of miyagi dough is about
lifestyle and philosophy and then zen
then to be disciplining anthony
it it's not just using cobra kai moves
he uses the cobra kai mentality to
discipline him and it did push him in
the right direction you know i thought
that was a clever because yeah like that
theme of balance runs throughout the
whole episode and for danny and amanda
but especially danny in that situation
it's more instead of him falling out of
balance it's no you need this other side
to balance you out and to help you teach
properly
run away with it andrew well before i
get into the references and easter eggs
i'd love that
i mean you talk about balance in this
episode which i totally agree with i
also think like a major theme in this
episode was role models and father
figures and sure that's just really what
uh you know took for me and what i you
know really you know gravitated towards
in this episode and you know when it
comes to uh johnny with miguel when it
comes to even crease to johnny when he
saw terry beating the [ __ ] out of him
like you know in that moment you felt
them as a father figure they're like
watching his his firstborn son being
beaten there and then also too with uh
daniel and anthony i mean and then
obviously robbie you know his animosity
towards miguel and i've loved how
they've kind of flipped the script and
what you guys were saying earlier where
you know throughout the first three
seasons robbie's had this animosity
towards miguel not only because you know
sam was so into him but because of the
relationship he had with uh his father
with johnny i mean we saw that in that
fir in uh one episode in season one when
he was about to go see his father at the
dojo and he's giving him the ghee and it
all started from there so to actually
see
robbie get into miguel's head and then
that heartbreaking moment in that
amazing scene
it's just it's a again the writers and
they're just incredible with the choices
they make i mean a lot of times you
think like okay here comes a cliche
moments like no they just pull the rug
from out under you in a very interesting
way so i appreciate that all right i
won't keep you waiting greg because i
know you want to hear something
all right well the episode's down all
right
calm down grace the episode was called
party time i think we all understand
that reference it was from lethal weapon
karate kid part three uh also too we get
a party on of course that is a reference
to wayne's world 1992 the same year my
cousin vinnie came out which we got the
marissa tomei reference played by julia
machio who is of course ralph macchio's
daughter
yeah
just watching you connect the threads
here it's awesome six degrees of i don't
know what and then you're charlie damien
not much happened in this episode so i
was just thinking about the easter eggs
and the references okay guys
and sorry the dojo of course as they
pointed out in the flashbacks was in the
first film and part three where miyagi
kicked the crap out of terry silver and
mike barnes and uh sensei crease and we
got the whoa
it can't be the same dojo though
it looked like the same one i can
confirm it's not oh
set wise
spit some easter eggs are you ready for
this andrew it's not lakersham and
magnolia guys
andrew the cobra kai dojo featured in
karate kid one and three was where i
john temporarily chained and trained and
i was there for for like 10 years where
i trained in taekwondo and it was that
exact dojo that they shot at they loved
being reminded of it they had photos of
karate kid framed on the walls because
that was the exact dojo where they shot
it and i happen to know that they uh
shut down that dojo and it's replaced
with some like aerobic place now
and that build that so it's very much
intact and it's not under some building
that's been shut down or in construction
and then when they did show the exterior
because they had the shots of lakership
magnolia but when they showed
the sidewalk of lancashire
that's lankership but that's not
magnolia yeah
and uh cause uh yeah no in fact i think
now it's a new age store is it oh they
changed to even a new store now yeah
it's been a few things you're closer to
north hollywood than i yeah it's
crystals and things now and incense well
there you go see they they've that that
building's still very much intact so
they didn't design the interior but i
was like i can tell the differences by
the size of this that this is also
definitely not the same one
but yes it is going back to the karate
kid 3 dojo john
you know what i appreciated about this
episode was uh i'm always fascinated by
where john crees's line is
and i still don't feel like i know
but it was very striking to watch terry
unload on johnny and have crease be the
one to be like wait wait wait wait wait
this isn't the right way to handle this
he does give miss signals yeah i mean
that's he has to understand that he's
given mixed signals that's the one thing
is because yeah he has that whole
exchange with terry about like you know
we gotta take it to him and we gotta you
know can't stand for anything and terry
talks him into the whole like no no
let's wait till the tournament and let's
not fight anybody till then and play the
long game and now kris is on board with
that and not to say that there isn't a
way where those things don't make sense
together and and from a performance
perspective i was very gripped in that
moment but it is sort of like okay i
wonder if we will get any closer to
truly knowing because it seems like
crease
at a certain point i would have said
like crease was totally capable of being
the one to be like well let's kick
johnny's ass
uh but even so like i really like that
fight scene back and forth and it seems
like especially thomas ian griffith like
keeps up with the moves because like a
couple of their shots seemed like they
were uncut with them throwing those
kicks and yeah they're full shots here
and yeah again i know we've touched this
point before but i think they're doing a
really nice job this season of yeah
having a bunch of story lines
all of which don't necessitate a fight
scene every episode even though
somewhere you get karate you get fight
training and this one obviously has like
the prom fight
um and you know this couple stingray
moments but i don't know like i
appreciate that all this other stuff
everything with anthony and you know
danny and amanda going through couples
counseling and things like that like all
those things are still effective
and i still care about them i'm not just
like when can we get back to the
craziness
um so like yeah it's it's really a
testament to that it's like all the
nuances and all the things that are
really affecting i really appreciate and
i don't know like i think that in season
four it would be really easy for the
show to lose steam or to become
repetitive but i feel like they've
really continued to fine tune it
well i think with miguel and samantha it
was so
so cool to see how they handled that
because
as much as there's like this animosity
and antagonism happening with the
characters there's
there's uh this
you have tori and robbie coming together
and you have sam and miguel falling
apart all based off of the observations
and reflections that are happening with
each other at prom night yeah and it's
really cool it's interesting to see like
tori and robbie get to the point where
they're not affected by miguel and sam
like in terms of
emotional like romantic attraction
attachment all that stuff
whereas that's like corrupting miguel
and sam throughout the night of any
unresolved
conflicts or feelings that has uh
incurred between them
and like it's i don't know i just
thought it was like so well done to
watch the yid and yang of this and then
how tori and
robbie end in a way where it's good for
them and yet it's like so bad for
daniel i mean for sam and mcgill sam and
miguel yeah
miguellum
savelle
samuel
samwell what i took from all that what
you guys just said is you wanted to be
cobra kai that's why you went to that
dojo and train there is that what you
guys are that's all we ever wanted all
we ever wanted was johnny's
line to strike first show no mercy the
way the fist well they they dig
this karate kid but it was taekwondo
[Music]
it's like jurassic park doesn't actually
have jurassic period monsters yeah
well that doesn't miss one reference
when um
miguel is uh helping johnny while he's
drunk that's a reference to uh the
karate kid with jaden smith and jackie
chan
when jackie chan is drunk at one point
i'm only seeing the movie once does he
get drunk in that movie i think he does
he does
smith comes home drunk
that was gene smith was going to come
into that scene and help johnny like oh
wrong universe doctor strange open the
portal my bad no you're not my miyagi
it's coming
i'm under her house
no it's gonna end
we got so we got uh just what two more
episodes left two more episodes yeah
it's on to season five sometime
and just add one more thing to what you
said uh in regards to robbie and tori i
really liked how they were really just
taking terry silver's lessons of you
know striking first in a different type
of way where they were manipulating uh
these two and obviously they didn't care
as when you know what started out as
manipulation turned into romantic
emotions and i thought that was a really
smart move but again i like how they're
playing off of what terry was teaching
them about hey everyone's got a weakness
and you just got to figure it out you
know there's there's a different way of
striking so i really appreciate that
just coming back to what terry was
teaching them yeah amen to that sister
all right guys well cobra kai two more
to go
and then we're done so
goodbye show not ready to let go i'm
ready
i'm ready i'm over this show yeah i hate
the show it's not that interesting
what we should do next time we shouldn't
review anything
we should just
watch it all in one day yeah and then
just cut it up like that yeah yeah yeah
that wouldn't take too much time
yeah
cut it down to 10 minutes
the whole show 10 episodes in 10 minutes
no no context at all for the reactions
none
randomize the chapters too
yeah so people really really have to
keep watching i mean we technically
could just watch it all and then um yeah
i just watched it all in one sitting
because how long is it let's say every
episode is roughly 30 to 40 minutes
let's average it out to like 33 minutes
an episode 33 times 333 minutes
yeah what is that the snyder cup
restore the sniper first wait a minute
333 minutes what would that be like in
hours
five hours
yeah that's five hours and 33 minutes
everybody changed
to see like by episode four or five just
how we're like you know not only
reacting but just like our prowess and
just like how tired we are from all that
yeah
johnny lawrence
johnny
all right guys
all right we're we're leaving now bye
[Music]